[Aplausos]
[Música]
en el campo de batalla la Guerra de
Ucrania ha sido un gran fracaso para
Rusia sin embargo Esta no es la única
mala noticia político militar que ha
sufrido el kremlin uno de los grandes
argumentos que
Moscú utilizó para intentar justificar
su atroz invasión fue la de impedir a
toda Costa que la otan continuara
expandiéndose hacia el este según el
gobierno ruso esto suponía para ellos un
riesgo absolutamente inaceptable hoy
queridos amigos amigas las cosas han
dado un giro de 180 grados la invasión
de Ucrania hizo que países como
Finlandia o Suecia se plantearán cambiar
su estatus si hasta ahora habían ido por
libres la invasión les convenció de que
eso ya no era nada recomendable tenían
Sí o sí que sumarse la otan en abril del
2023 lo hizo Finlandia
making finland
aliens stronger raise the Finish
sin embargo Suecia lo ha tenido mucho
más difícil hasta ahora
Finalmente y pese a todos los tira y
afloja que veremos en este vídeo Suecia
se convertirá en el trigésimo segundo
miembro de la alianza atlántica y ojo
porque esto no es algo que le haga
ninguna gracia a Rusia de hecho llevan
años diciendo y haciendo cosas como esta
fijaos 18 de junio de 2015 embajador
ruso si Suecia se une la otan habrá
consecuencias Putin señaló que habrá
consecuencias que Rusia tendrá que
recurrir a una respuesta de tipo militar
y reorientar nuestras tropas y misiles 4
de Febrero de 2016 Rusia simula un
ataque nuclear contra Suecia admite la
otan con una extensión de unos 450.000
kilómetros cuadrados y Casi 11 millones
de habitantes Suecia es el tercer país
más extenso de toda la Unión Europea y
la gran potencia escandinava La pregunta
es por qué Suecia preocupa tanto al
kremlin que supone Exactamente para la
otan la inclusión de este país realmente
Esto es algo que puede preocuparle a
Rusia qué es lo que cambiará a partir de
ahora pues en este vídeo vamos a
responder a todas estas preguntas y para
entender bien toda esta historia lo
primero será empezar por el principio
vamos con ello
Pero antes Te has parado a pensar en lo
que te estás perdiendo por no usar lo
primero de todo y más importante es la
seguridad en la red con surfshark tu
actividad online está protegida como si
fuera for nox cifrada y a salvo de ojos
curiosos que quieran meter mano a tus
datos además con cleanweb te despides de
los anuncios y el malware y tus emails
Pues con Surf alert te enteras al
instante si alguien ha intentado filtrar
tu información pero un momento porque
hay más surfshark es la primera VPN
comercial que tiene servidores en más de
un centenar de países Imagínate es como
tener un pasaporte global a solo un clic
puedes acceder a cualquier contenido
bloqueado por ubicación Y si te preocupa
tener que elegir en Qué dispositivo
usarlo tranquilo con la misma cuenta
puedes proteger todos tus dispositivos
ya sea tu móvil tu tablet la tele o el
ordenador y un pequeño secreto aquí
entre tú y yo puedes compartir la cuenta
con tus amigos así entre todos cada uno
paga unos céntimos al mes además por ser
parte de la comunidad visualpolitik
podrás disfrutar de tres meses extra
totalmente gratis usando el código
politik y ahora sí arranquemos busquemos
todas las respuestas
[Música]
del imperio a la neutralidad
en la cultura y en la imaginación
popular siempre solemos ver a Suecia
como un estado tranquilo y moderado un
reducto de paz social y el Santas
actorum de la socialdemocracia moderna
Claro que esto no siempre fue así su
pasado fue mucho más intimidante el
Imperio sueco fue una de las potencias
europeas más poderosas del siglo XVII
por aquel momento su territorio incluía
también las actuales Finlandia Estonia y
buena parte de Noruega y la pregunta es
por qué os contamos todo esto en
visualpolitik Pues porque la
configuración del territorio actual en
esta región de Europa responde a los
acontecimientos provocados por la
conocida como La gran guerra del Norte
hablamos de un conflicto entre 1700 y
1721 durante esos años el Imperio sueco
mantuvo un conflicto armado contra Rusia
Dinamarca y Noruega precisamente por la
supremacía en el mar Báltico
el conflicto terminó con el tratado de
nistat en 1721 con este tratado Suecia
fue doblegada ante el zarismo Ruso y eso
no es todo algunas décadas más tarde
entre los años 1808 y 1809 estalló la
conocida como guerra finlandesa donde
Rusia volvió a prevalecer sobre Suecia
Entonces el gran ducado de Finlandia
pasó a estar bajo control de San
Petersburgo por aquel entonces la
capital del imperio ruso
[Música]
y así de esta forma poco a poco Rusia se
fue convirtiendo en una gran potencia
báltica este mar Dejó de ser una especie
de Lago exclusivo de imperio sueco para
llegar a convertirse con el paso del
tiempo en la salida natural de la flota
rusa hacia los mares del mundo
por su parte Suecia a partir del siglo
XIX y tras haber perdido su antigua
grandeza Imperial adoptó una política de
neutralidad la reorganización del estado
y el desarrollo del país pasaron a ser
sus grandes prioridades Hablamos de una
neutralidad que durante más de 150 años
Prácticamente solo fue puesta en
cuestión durante la Segunda Guerra
Mundial puesta en cuestión que no rota
formalmente Suecia no se adhirió a
ninguno de los dos bandos y más tarde en
1949 cuando la Segunda Guerra Mundial ya
había dado paso a la Guerra Fría
estocolmo optó por mantenerse fuera de
la otan y declarar una política de
seguridad basada en la independencia y
la neutralidad
con todo en los 90 llegó a Suecia una
ola de entusiasmo europeísta de tal
forma que en 1995 este país decidió
finalmente romper con su histórica
política de estado integrarse la Unión
Europea además aunque se mantuvo fuera
de la otan sí que reforzó sus lazos con
esta organización por ejemplo durante
todos estos años ha participado como
afiliado como Aliado y no como miembro
de misiones de la otan en Bosnia kosovo
Afganistán y Libia
y eso no es todo en 2007 Suecia se unió
a Finlandia Noruega Estonia Irlanda
letonia y lituania dentro del grupo de
combate nórdico uno de los grupos de
combate de la Unión Europea cuyo cuartel
general está Precisamente en la
localidad sueca de y en shopping Desde
allí se dirige un grupo de reserva de
2400 soldados de dichos países
[Música]
es decir que la neutralidad sueca
comenzó a desaparecer a toda velocidad
algo que podéis creernos a Vladimir
Putin no le hizo ninguna gracia y os
preguntaréis Qué hizo Entonces el líder
ruso Pues básicamente hacer lo que mejor
sabe hacer poner en marcha una campaña
constante de intimidación su objetivo
evitar toda Costa que Suecia decidiera
unirse a la alianza atlántica 11 de
septiembre de 2014 acciones militares
rusas en el Báltico sin precedentes el
ministro de defensa polaco toma simoniac
dijo que la mayor parte de la actividad
se produjo en aguas y espacios
internacionales y que Suecia fue el país
más afectado 24 de marzo de 2015 Suecia
intercepta aviones militares rusos que
vuelan con sus transpondedores apagados
sobre la región del Báltico 27 octubre
de 2016 Rusia refuerza la flota báltica
en medio de las tensiones de la otan el
ministro de defensa de Suecia dijo que
su país estaba preocupado por la
presencia de Los buques de guerra en el
mar Báltico y se quejó de que la medida
probablemente mantendría alta la tensión
en la región Pero por qué le importa
tanto a Rusia lo que pueden hacer países
como Finlandia o Suecia pues lo vamos a
ver en un momento En este mismo vídeo y
ya os adelanto que las implicaciones de
la adhesión de Suecia y Finlandia son
mucho más grandes de lo que podríamos
imaginar pero por ahora lo que tenemos
que tener claro es que la estrategia
rusa no ha funcionado la invasión de
Ucrania desató consecuencias inesperadas
para Rusia si el objetivo del kremlin
era dar un golpe en la mesa al final el
miedo a la irracionalidad de los rusos
hizo que tanto Finlandia como Suecia
entendieran que todo eso de la
neutralidad e ir por libre ya no era una
opción formar parte de la otan era la
única vía real para garantizar su
seguridad y sabéis que como decimos por
aquí dicho y hecho en las bases de
helsinki ya ondea la bandera de la otan
pronto lo hará también en las de Suecia
Pero por qué se ha demorado tanto la
adhesión de este país Pues básicamente
porque había cuentas pendientes de qué
estamos hablando exactamente Pues ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
[Aplausos]
escollos en el camino
queridos amigos para que un país pueda
adherirse a la otan todos sus miembros
tienen que estar de acuerdo y dar su
visto bueno eso con Finlandia fue
relativamente fácil pero en el caso de
Suecia bueno digamos que dos países
miembros de la otan se empeñaron en que
las cosas no fueran tan sencillas el
primer país ha sido la Turquía de
erdogan durante meses el gobierno Turco
ha denunciado que Suecia respaldaba y
daba cobijo a los militantes de
organizaciones kurdas y el gobierno
Turco considera grupos terroristas y
enemigos del Estado además hasta
septiembre del 22 Suecia también
mantenía un embargo a la venta de armas
contra Turquía por las operaciones de
este país en el norte de Siria Y claro
con estos dos precedentes estaba Claro
que las negociaciones no iban a ser
coser y cantar con todo el 11 de
septiembre del 22 se produjo un cambio
de color político en Suecia el gobierno
pasó de lo socialdemócratas a una
coalición de partidos conservadores un
cambio que facilitó que se aprobara una
nueva ley antiterrorista que entre otras
limitaba el respaldo sueco a la causa
kurda más tarde en octubre se reunieron
delegados de los ministerios de justicia
de Suecia y de Turquía para tratar
algunas posibles extradiciones
reclamadas por ankara
[Música]
de esta forma pese a los históricos
roces todo parecía ir viento en popa Y
así fue hasta que en enero del 23 todo
saltó otra vez más por los aires
entonces una activista danés protestó en
el exterior de la embajada turca en
estocolmo y quemó un ejemplar del Corán
esto provocó importantes protestas en
muchos Países Árabes y desató la ira del
gobierno de erdogan fijaos
que dice que todo esto no era más que
una especie de teatrillo de segunda de
esta forma la negativa de Turquía
durante todo este tiempo a la adhesión
de Suecia podría haber respondido no
solo a las malas relaciones de ankara
con estocolmo sino sobre todo con
Washington Sí sí me habéis escuchado
bien con Washington Y es que veréis me
explico las relaciones entre Estados
Unidos y Turquía llevan años siendo
bastante malas y de hecho el presidente
ha tenido sobre su escritorio durante
meses varios paquetes de venta de armas
a Turquía pendientes de aprobación entre
ellos la venta de aviones f-16 de Última
Generación y como Estados Unidos estaba
como loco con que Suecia entrara de una
vez por todas a la otan Turquía puede
haber aprovechado la ocasión para
presionar al Tío Sam 11 de julio de 2023
Estados Unidos despeja el camino para
las ventas de f-16 a Turquía en medio de
la expansión de la otan La pregunta es
si ha salido con la suya Pues el tiempo
nos dirá
luego el otro país que también ha
entorpecido la integración de Suecia ha
sido Hungría erdogan y orbán El caso es
que en el marco de la Unión Europea
Suecia es prácticamente la antítesis de
Hungría en Prácticamente todo desde la
inmigración a las políticas lgtbi
pasando por la política social y
ambiental o la posición respecto a la
Guerra de Ucrania 5 de octubre de 2016
Suecia amenaza con demandar Hungría por
denegación de asilo el ministro de
justicia de Suecia Morgan Johansson dijo
que Suecia desafiar a Hungría y los
tribunales A menos que comience a
aceptar a solicitantes de asilo de otros
países de la Unión Europea 20 de febrero
de 2019 las relaciones entre Suecia
Hungría se congelan a medida que aumenta
la disputa diplomática la ministra
socialdemócrata de asuntos sociales de
Suecia ánica strangham escribió en
Twitter que la política de planificación
familiar de 7 puntos del Primer Ministro
Víctor Urban apesta la década de 1930 y
que lo que está sucediendo en Hungría es
alarmante
of libro
sea como sea al final Suecia entrará en
la otan la pregunta lo más importante de
todas y que aún tenemos pendiente de
responder es por qué demonios es tan
importante para la otan la adhesión de
dos países relativamente poco poblados
como Suecia y como Finlandia Por qué
decimos que esto supone un enorme
varapalo para los intereses de Rusia Por
qué durante años
Moscú quiso evitar a toda Costa este
escenario Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver
[Música]
la última pieza del rompecabezas
fijaos en lo que decía en 2016 un
informe del centro internacional de
defensa y seguridad con sede en Estonia
sin Suecia y Finlandia la otan la
alianza carece de profundidad
estratégica y operativa en la región y
también de capacidad suficiente para
ejercer un mayor control sobre el
espacio marítimo y aéreo en el mar
Báltico si Rusia consiguiera obligar a
estocolmo y helsinki a mantenerse al
margen de un conflicto en el Báltico las
opciones de respuesta de la otan se
verían aún más limitadas pero porque es
tan importante que Suecia y Finlandia se
integren en la otan Pues bien la
respuesta la podéis ver claramente en
este mapa
[Música]
tras la anexión de criminal 2014 y
Estados Unidos realizó una variedad de
juegos de guerra para buscar debilidades
estratégicas en las fronteras de la otan
estos juegos mostraron que la isla sueca
de gotland jugaría un papel clave en el
caso hipotético de tener que defender
las repúblicas bálticas si llegado el
caso Rusia a cortar al corredor de
subauqui se apoderará de gotland para
desplegar en ella sistemas de defensa
aérea tal y como podéis ver en el mapa
de las repúblicas bálticas prácticamente
quedarían atrapadas sería muy difícil
poder acudir en su auxilio y ni siquiera
habría que llegar tan lejos con que
Rusia impidiera la otan utilizar esa
Isla un ataque híbrido contra los
bálticos incluso con tropas No
identificadas como ya ocurrió en crimea
podría ser una pesadilla para las
fuerzas atlánticas Esta es O mejor dicho
era una de las grandes bazas que a largo
plazo ha tenido Rusia
y eso no es todo
la integración de Finlandia y sobre todo
de Suecia en la otan también acaba con
la mayor parte del valor estratégico de
kaliningrado ahora la otan podría
llegado el caso cortar muy fácilmente
las comunicaciones entre este territorio
y el resto de Rusia digamos que la flota
rusa del Báltico aquí desplegada deja de
tener capacidad para moverse libremente
y no solo eso llegado el caso Rusia ni
siquiera podría hacer llegar suministros
a este enclave y ojo porque esto
refuerza la idea que tienen muchos
analistas de que tarde o temprano
kaliningrado terminará fuera de Rusia
algo de lo que os hablaremos muy pronto
en patreon y Exactamente lo mismo ocurre
con la entrada y salida de mercancías
desde y al mercado mundial Rusia depende
en gran medida del comercio que
atraviesa el Báltico para abastecerse y
vender sus productos al resto del mundo
ahora esas comunicaciones estarán
supeditadas al visto bueno de la otan Y
eso tampoco es todo la capacidad de la
Fuerza Aérea rusa para alcanzar
posiciones en el resto de Europa también
se verá muy limitada En otras palabras
si durante décadas el mar Báltico fue un
mar controlado por Rusia que le daba
acceso al mismísimo corazón de Europa a
su armada y a su fuerza aérea ahora eso
ha dejado de ser así la integración de
Finlandia y de Suecia en la otan ha
cortado de raíz esa posibilidad
de hecho la otan Finlandia y Estonia ya
han anunciado ambiciosos planes para
tener la capacidad de cerrar llegado el
caso el golfo de Finlandia Asimismo en
2022 Rusia anunció planes para
reconstruir su poder marítimo en la zona
ahora Esos planes son papel mojado con
la entrada de Suecia y Finlandia en la
otan en el mar Báltico quedará rodeado
por Estados miembros de la otan el
objetivo de establecer el poder marítimo
ruso proclamado de nuevo en 2022 con la
publicación de la nueva doctrina naval
rusa sería ahora inviable en esta región
de importancia estratégica y si la flota
báltica de Rusia con todo esto es
prácticamente historia la futura
integración de Ucrania en la otan hará
que ocurra lo mismo con la flota del mar
Negro pero ese es otro asunto siguiendo
con Suecia Aunque este país tiene un
ejército relativamente pequeño aporta la
alianza una importante industria militar
Y ojo porque las fábricas suecas
producen no solo armas pequeñas sino
sistemas avanzados como aviones de
combate misiles tanques submarinos
corbetas y plataformas de defensa aérea
creemos que vamos a contribuir a la
defensa de los aliados no tenemos unas
fuerzas armadas tan numerosas como
Finlandia pero Contamos con las
tecnologías más avanzadas y empresas de
defensa muy potentes es decir que la
adhesión de Suecia la otan supone sin
exagerar uno de los mayores saltos en
términos de seguridad para toda Europa
de las últimas décadas la operación
militar especial de Putin logró que
Rusia pasase de compartir 841 kilómetros
de fronteras con la otan en 2021 a más
de 2100 tras la entrada de Finlandia
ahora la integración de Suecia se
supondrá perder también toda su
influencia en el mar Báltico el desastre
en términos estratégicos es colosal pero
llegamos hasta aquí turno para ti Cómo
crees que responderá Rusia a la
integración de Suecia en la otan crees
que el siguiente paso tiene que ser
lograr que kaliningrado se separe del
resto de Rusia déjanos tus impresiones
en los comentarios y hablamos debate y
ahora si este vídeo te ha resultado
interesante No olvides darle al botón de
like y suscribirte a visualpolitik si es
que aún no lo has hecho y recordad con
el código politik acabado en K podréis
disfrutar de tres meses extra totalmente
gratis con surfshark el link como
siempre abajo en la descripción una vez
más Muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]